hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rabbit championship it's around 12
and magnus carlsen is the sole leader
after 11 rounds in the previous game he
drew a game against Maxime varsha
lagravis upper tunity but too quickly
went for the endgame now he faces 11
Arnon he again gets the black pieces but
you already mentioned that on the final
day he will have black three times and
or white only twice so without further
ado let's check it out eleven opens with
d4 with Knight to f6 c4 with east six
nine to f3 and d5 with nice to see three
and now c5 going for the same opening he
went for against grant Malcolm young who
is also from Armenia we've covered his
game from this world rabbit championship
and hunt milkman is also I don't know if
he's currently but he was 11 origins
seconds so I'm sure in both Levin and
Malcolm young know the line that that
Magnus place we have seek after Sun b5e
cap person d5 so everything the same as
in the game cousin Malcolm young g3 and
nice to see six we have Bishop the g2
preparing the castle see capture Sun d4
Knight captures and Bishop to c5 so
following constants game against Malcolm
young Knight captures and c6 b captures
and here we have castles Magnus also
castles and Queen to c2 so still
following that game we have Bishop to b6
now and Knight to a4 and the Bishop to
d7 and this is where the game takes a
different approach here if you remember
no command played there and night and
night character sake a person before he
grabbed hold of the c5 square not
allowing the Magnus to push c5 but here
we have b3 by 11 it's a new move in the
position and it is as a move 13 that we
have a completely new game so what's the
idea okay
Magnus continues with rook to e8 Bishop
to b2 by 11 I think a doing the dark
square bishop as well and now h5 just
preparing h4 and hoping the bust open
the the King side and it was here about
at this moment where Magnus started
smiling for some reason maybe he had
this
you know on the board at home maybe
maybe he knows that it's not as good as
the line Malcolm implied here we even
have a nice photo of him smiling at this
moment after he pushed h5 so let's just
enjoyed that for a moment and of course
the Levin doesn't want to allow well he
doesn't want to see a h4 on the board so
he pushes H for himself and the time on
the clock was thirteen and a half
minutes Levin and the 16 minutes calls
and so Magnus had more hair than when he
started with Knight to e4 by Magnus
putting pressure on DF do porn although
for the moment it's protected
III blocking the dark square Bishop and
rook to c8 now and here a final 11
captures with Knight captures pawn
captures and now Queen to d1 going after
the h5 pawn and here Bishop to f5
there's also there is also the sneaky
Bishop to g4 but it doesn't do all that
much for black f3 Knight captures and g3
you give up the bishop and now Queen
captures on h4 and it's a Cessna key
position but most likely cousin checked
ideas like this at home and he knows
that it doesn't work a Queen f3 defense
you do grab the rope but after rook
captures here it's a yes White has two
bishops for a rook and even though Black
has six points White has only four it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be a problem
for white so after Bishop f5 we have
Queen captures on h5 and now you have
two well defend your Bishop I hope none
of you are considering g6 to allow
something like Quinta h8 made to don't
forget about you know our our good
friend the Bishop on b2 so after a Queen
to h5 we have Queen to d7 defending the
bishop also preparing Bishop to h3 at
some point
Queen back to d1 it was it was just a
pawn grab and now c5 continuing in this
expansion which is possible in this line
in the line that Malcolm um played upon
was here so it was a somewhat
problematic and here you you can't
really dislodge this night with a Bishop
capture because then you just weak in
your light light squares too much we've
looked at a one
and now rook C to d8 we have cooked the
c1 bringing the last rook into the game
and not brush up the h3 by Magnus we
have Queen to f3
and now f6 numbing the the dark square
bishop
we have Bishop captures on h3 Queen
captures on h3 and not rook C to D 1 and
Magnus continues to push on the Queen
side with b5 one of these points is
coming forward at some point so xi has
to take all of these pawn pushes into
consideration we have Queen to g2 11
offers the Queen trade and Queen back to
e6 of course Magnus not interested
we have f3 pushing the knight back
there's this or you allow this night to
remain here forever
we have Knight back to d6 and now g4 and
here Magnus has to decide whether he
wants to block the position would be for
whether he wants to go Knight a 7 arre
maneuver this Knight over to e5
challenge 11 whether he wants to further
expand would f4 to create some
additional weaknesses but he goes for
the straight forward d4 as Levin is
lower on time he takes this opportunity
to to make him waste more time and here
11 goes Queen to d2 also you could go it
captures on d4 but then you just get
Queen captures here and the two rooks
for a queen are well worth it check King
moves now look here threatening to come
to e2 and well black black will just win
this very nicely
so after d4 we have Queen to d2 by 11
and now Queen to d5 putting pressure on
the f3 pawn 11 says okay ECAP force on
d4 says do you want to capture on f3 and
it's a really complicated line but
Magnus decides against it if Queen
captures here you get Queen g2 Queen to
f4 now avoiding the trade D captures on
c5 and not rook captures any one rook
captures anyone and now you get this
position where well it's an open board
anything can happen but even though
White's King is a bit more exposed
Magnus doesn't doesn't enjoy this but
because it's it's not all that all that
easy to play Plus you do have to worry
about the passport knight of seven c6 is
coming so now it's impossible to
calculate this position so we have C for
my
Magnus instead he plays it even but it
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine and now you already have some
ideas of B for followed by C 3 if
possible and 11 has to decide what to do
here first 11 goes Bishop to e3 it gets
the best part of the way he doesn't want
this pawn reaching c3 while the bishop
is there so Bishop to e3 puts pressure
on the night here and now Magnus goes
Queen captures on f3 so what changed
that the Queen captures an f3 is
playable now well 11 goes Queen to g2
and now rook captures any one rook
captures and Queen back the c3 now
putting pressure on the d4 pawn and also
under rook anyone we have looked a d1
getting rid of both threats but now
before this is what changed so those
were the three threats the capture on d4
character here and did the b4 you could
11 couldn't have stopped both of them we
push it back to be 2 and now the Queen
guards it so you have to move the Queen
Queen III trick Queen to F 2 blocks and
Queen to h3 now so what's what's
Carson's idea he wants the capture on g4
with check and pick up the rook on d1 so
Queen back to g2 offering a queen try
the wall guarding the g4 pawn and here
you could capture on h4 a but Magnus
decides against it Magnus goes for a
Quinta III once again Queen to f2 and
now Quinta efore going after the g4 pawn
this way and here which prevents white
from eliminating the c-4 point and
that's crucial if you allow c3 then it's
just bad but you have to guard against
this Queen g2 now Magnus pushes c3 and
creates a very strong past c3 pawn push
it back to c1 and the now even see - so
you have to go rook f1 if you go up the
board and just Queenie the Queen e1
check threatens to win the bishop after
you block locate it's just a dominating
position for Magnus so after c2 we have
looked the f1 and now comes Queen
captures on d4 sorry Queen captures on
d4 with check King to h2 and now Queen
to e5 with check again with King to g1
and now Queen to c5 with check
now the Cebu bond is nicely protected
with pink the h2 in the now night-night
to have seven finally preparing to bring
this night into the game and eleven
without all that many ideas and without
a lot of time 11 has some 20 seconds on
the clock whereas the Magnus's or above
two minutes pushes g5 and okay queen 'if
I've checked again we have King you
cannot trade Queens if you trade Queens
then just characters captures and the
rook to d1 eliminates all of White's
counter play you cannot capture you
cannot move the rook it's just it's just
a terrible position so after a queen in
five we have Kings the h1 but now rook
to d1 again you cannot capture because
the the c2 point just Queens and you
cannot capture the c2 point because rook
captures and f1 you you'll be leaving
the rook undefended
so g6 by 11 Knight back to d8 and now
Queen to f3 and here Magnus should
continue with the rugby for just you
know creating some additional threats
but like in the game against Maxime
it seems that Magnus is so confident in
his endgame steel skills that he just
wants the tray down as soon as possible
so he plays rook captures an f1 Queen
captures and Quinta efore with Czech we
have Queen to g2 now defending and the
Queen captures on H forward to check
with team to g1 and now Queen back to d4
with check King to h2 and here Queen to
d1 the problem is here xi has Quinta
efore and this is what Magnus missed now
you cannot capture the bishop because
Quinta e whoa sorry about that
because Quinta I 8 is made and here
Magnus went for his famous head shake he
was very unpleasant the turn of events
he had to play King to f8 but now he
loses the b4 pawn with check we have
King - he ate and now Quinta b5 with
check King to e7 and here Queen the C
fight with check so it's very unlikely
that Carson will be able to wiggle out
of all the checks better up to a3 or
wasn't doing all that much so now Queen
the c5 check instead King the e6 and now
Queen the c8 with check here kink the if
I was played and this is the magical
moment of the game
I feel free to pause the video here and
tried to guess the movie that lemon
played don't look for the best mode just
try to guess the movie level and played
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
and find any move on the board there are
a lot of good moves here I just continue
checking the King Quincy five check
would be a check you know continue
checking the black ink
however 11 played a really weird move
here 11 played Queen to be seven and
that's just that's just weird
I was everyone was like what that's I
don't know there's no way to explain why
this happened but he did put his Queen
only seven Magnus just captured it and
that's just it it was a nice nice queen
capture and well yes it was in this
position on more fifty-eight that eleven
ariane resigned the game in in a in a
way that I don't think he ever resigned
the game but it happens you know if you
look at it throughout chess history you
know players did wonders like like like
this you know in short time time trouble
in time trouble eleven was in time
trouble here you know so it happens but
it was you know meeting one again
against carp of chocking on and also
meeting one kramnik missing meeting one
against against deep Fritz so it happens
but yeah really really awesome stuff
after risking if I've moved just Queen
to be seven so crazy stuff but yeah and
this does wonders for for Coulson as he
is now again the sole leader grabbing a
full point against Levin onion and with
three more rounds to go it's gonna be
very interesting to see if Magnus can
keep this up so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it 11 well I don't
know how 11 will be will recover after
this for the next three games will be
very impressed if he does I would like
to thank Michael Carey Pete spawn robust
Victor Klein the adavi gross skinned and
preserved for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon contain
the coverage of the feed a world rapid
and bliss championship until it ends for
the next three days so thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your Saturday